remember 120 live right behind them but
like 118 119 but Denver's winning then
replied seven and three over that 10
game stretched blades of the three and
seven Anthony Tolliver committed his
first pot you see what he ends up doing
tonight nice Matt he worked hard but he
didn't play it out of minutes that's
what he can do he's feeling nice and
easy rebound for him all the way down
yes and one keep the pressure on him
young fella under man in terms of rent
protection insides and yeah this is just
going to attack CJ McCollum and then a
nice job number three in the league and
ISO points got a little bit of a nice
sole I guess let's on that possession
smoothly done Chris Middleton home road
road I've heard Road excuse me I've
heard home to road as the awful one
Chris Middleton there with the three you
know we'll try like home road home it's
worth more stressful other to these guys
mentally than anything else
Matthew's missing from the corner Yanis
the rebound he lays it in softly that
reminds me that Hassan Whiteside turned
in with the players are now calling a
Barbara Walters he had the first 2020 of
2025 Oh Walters in the 2020 manual fires
in blue a go yes for three he has 13
points
speaking of wits in Portland great
defensive worked by her side Elias sobah
against Lille led so smoothly on the
other
Yanis floats and has 15 points we're in
Paris that here's Janice it's a nice job
but getting that little chicken 314
against the Cavaliers hero 2 more 17
Coriana units jump he looks sharp on the
finishes McCallum on the miss here's
Bledsoe all the way in plus a foul
that's and he didn't get hit West had
off long but blowing he did he took a
took a shot to the chops this will be
replayed now by crew chief Pat Braverman
Willard's body depending on collar is
shaping up within their kid you Center
kids you know when is he gonna be able
to come back hey nice job Dante love to
see dad go camp behind the line as
giannis works in the post he goes right
through the post doesn't it Janice
already tonight a solid double-double 19
points and 12 rebounds
Weatherly Matthews there it is
that's pretty you know that's that
execution where they clear out that side
and poke the bear and you see what
happens
Chris Middleton over Bazemore to go with
21 points went so high Glasser and a
second another second chance point got
Matthews on his heels and then he is one
of the best sand league's I meant in
terms of pull-up scoring from the
mid-range there's another guy that's
pretty good Chris Middleton
lencho works behind the honest see what
happened on that play Yanis had beaten
it's the Bucks he averaged 31 in the two
games set against Milwaukee last season
here's Bledsoe Perry honest yes sir and
a foul and what do you do anyway you see
some defense who is that that's McCollum
on that right side of the floor nothing
he could do it 6-2 6-3 to deter Yanis
work ethic and showing up every day
prepared
[Applause]
and the parley that is to a nice payday
all right flex so beautifully dining
let's so kind of lulls him to sleep but
then explodes by Lillard and way ahead
to blood so kind of sets the screen
rolls doesn't get it wet so keeps shoots
scores three he's feeling good right now
very Blitzen ice challenge by Yanis
forcing the miss out of the cook boat
and Melo grabs him and then he was at
Bazemore talyvel on the red Camaro
Anthony 12 points nine rebounds for
Portland easy for Middleton isn't it
easy pickins and tiramisù Middleton is
all boys man 18 points
her brother coming in the game shooting
just a tick under 42 system the
three-point line but has had his
struggles in this game he has it my
goodness his move right with the ball is
released Kent Bazemore picking up his
third Middleton again for 323 points a
Sanford his parents are from the Orlando
area grew up idolizing Penny Hardaway
there is the flex and the market
powering his way through a crowd of
Blazers here nice job and looting
baseball academy down in Bradenton
Florida spending year down there after
reclassify most guys used to classify to
graduate early
there you go talk about Simon IMG
Academy down in Bradenton reclassified
and as a 19 year old graduate was able
to 16 for Carmelo Anthony Bledsoe able
to score two more than any other team in
the league let's--oh rattles home a
three from Yanis
this latest pass pretty one Bledsoe has
23 points three LEDs so here's the
Westland whatever watch this hesitation
there then push off that back foot for
the blow by and the great advantage when
you could do that like Bledsoe is right
here head up
she's the floor drive she's the offing
it's another Antoine well and Eric
fortunate he got really close Jim to the
cameraman
Bledsoe to making contact with the
camera
nice dab on the finish and you hope he's
not needed oh yeah Chris Middleton so
smooth 28 points people are
understanding now just what this team
and it is a team in every sense of the
word is all about